fighters from the Wagner mercenary group
are withdrawing from the Russian cities
of varanesh and rostovonton Wagner
troops took control of them during its
Mutiny on Saturday convoys came within
200 kilometers of Moscow before they
were ordered to return to their bases
was cheered by supporters as he left
rostov on Don for Belarus under an
agreement brokered by Belarus pagosian
and his Fighters won't be prosecuted
well our team of correspondents are
covering all aspects of this story we
are live in Moscow Washington and the
United Nations well first of all let's
begin in Moscow and talk to Yulia
shapovalova and Julia the loss of
questions still to be answered here one
of the main ones being whereas Vladimir
Putin and I guess a follow-up has he
been saying anything
well some Bella Russian sources just
reported that President lukashenko
Belarus spoke on the phone with Vladimir
Putin the conversation took place Sunday
morning but the information about it was
released just minutes ago no details
were revealed though so it's been the
first mention of Mr Putin since his
Saturday morning address to the nation
according to his spokesman Putin was
working in the Kremlin all day long on
Saturday uh the last thing we heard from
the Kremlin was that the goal to avoid
Bloodshed in Russia that might have
happened due to the Rebellion Rebellion
has been reached and Moscow highly
appreciated Mr lukashenko's mediation
efforts so it seems like the Kremlin has
taken a pause now of course there are
various opinions on what actually
happened in the country during the past
uh you know two or two days many people
continue giving Vladimir Putin their
overwhelming support called considering
him a very strong and wise leader
however many agreed there were the
Rebellion has dealt a heavy blow to
Putin's reputation and lukashenko's
mediation between Putin and preggersian
is very humiliating for the Russian
president
as he couldn't deal with his own
um his own man whom he had brought into
politics that he didn't show his
diplomatic and negotiating skills and
abilities and got lukashenko involved in
all that and that he promised to
severely punish all those participating
in the Mutiny but then he basically let
them all go so now many are waiting for
Mr Putin's next steps and Julia we have
some idea of what the immediate future
holds for progression but what is going
to happen to his Wagner Fighters now
well it's going to be very interesting
well the latest that we've had from his
press service is that he was not in
touch with them he was last seen leaving
rostob and it's unknown where he's at
the moment according to kremlin's
spokesman again the criminal case
against evgeny pregosian will be closed
and his Wagner fighters who participated
in Saturday's events that will not be
prosecuted and some of the fighters will
sign contracts with the ministry of
Defense so probably it will mean that
the group will be deprived of its
funding and probably it will be a
disbanded at least for a while but
also a very interesting question will
the Russian authorities any longer need
Wagner's Services inside and outside
Russia will they ever fight in Ukraine
so too many questions I should say but
some people say the situation around
Wagner might of course affects the
outcome of the special military
operation in Ukraine and reveal some
vulnerabilities of the current political
system here in Russia okay thank you so
much that is Julia shapovalova for us in
Moscow
were U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken says the Wagner mutiny shows a
crack and Putin's grip on power
this has been a devastating strategic
failure for Putin across virtually every
front economic military geopolitical
standing but again to the extent this
presents a uh a distraction a loss of
focus for the Russians that may help the
ukrainians on on the battlefield
well let's talk to Russell and Jordan
live in Washington D.C and the Biden
Administration is obviously keeping a
very close eye on developments we heard
a little bit from uh blinken there what
else did he have to say
Anthony blinken also stressed
lower level U.S officials have been in
touch with their Russian counterparts to
stress the importance of protecting U.S
citizens throughout this crisis the
Secretary of State also indicated that
the U.S has no indication that there's
been any threat or compromise of
Russia's nuclear Arsenal the secretary
of state was asked several times during
his appearances on the Sunday public
affairs shows whether or not the U.S
believed that this was the beginning of
the end of Vladimir Putin's leadership
and blinken consistently insisted that
the U.S has no way of understanding how
this is going to play out beyond the
suggestion that it might take several
months for this crisis to be resolved
the the final point of which the
secretary wanted to underscore is the
fact that the U.S and its allies are
very much focused on helping Ukraine
deal with the effects of Russia's
Invasion a year ago February and that
it's going to continue putting its
energy into supporting Ukraine's efforts
to regain all of its territory and
uphold its sovereignty okay thank you so
much that's Russell and Jordan for us in
Washington D.C
okay well let's broaden this out with
our diplomatic editor James Bays who is
live at the U.N headquarters in New York
and obviously like the US the
International Community has been keeping
a very close eye on this everyone's had
24 hours or so to digest the latest
developments is there still a bit of
wonder about how this is actually going
to play out in the long term
so many questions I think but there is
some relief that there wasn't a battle
in Moscow there wasn't a a mass
um very large death toll and of course
there would have been the uncertainty of
what would happen to the nuclear Arsenal
Russia has more nuclear um Warheads than
any other Nation on Earth and I don't
think anyone uh watching this
particularly wanted Mr pagosian to take
over from Mr Putin because I think even
Mr Putin's
first vehement opponents would say Mr
pregosian was an even worse option I
think people are trying to work out what
happens next but they don't know any of
the details we don't know details of
that deal we don't know where pragosian
is right now we don't know where Putin
is right now so there are lots and lots
of question marks everyone I think on
the Russian side looks to have been
weakened by what has happened one
intriguing bit of information that's
come out in the last 24 hours is the
fact that U.S intelligence knew that Mr
pagosian was planning something they
knew that but clearly Mr Putin didn't so
the Russian side I think all look very
weakened which I think potentially uh
helps the ukrainians uh in their ongoing
war and their ongoing uh
counter-offensive the one figure that
perhaps looks strong is president
lukashenka of um of Belarus because he
brokered the deal but one person I spoke
to said well be a little careful there
he's a very rich man he's got lots of
weapons and he's now going to be based
in Belarus he could start becoming a
state with an estate and then become
down the line a headache from Mr
lukashenka I think everyone is also
looking at at the way the Optics fall
around the world with regard to this and
I think it's generally seen as a good
thing for the war in Ukraine by the
Western allies of Ukraine for example
here in the U.S it has been on TV for
the last 24 hours non-stop now the war
in uh Ukraine in fact Global events do
not really make the TV news very much
here in the United States
um and I think that helps the Biden
administration because there has been
some Ukraine fatigue there have been
Republicans on Capitol Hill who've been
saying why are we spending all this
money on Ukraine so that I think uh is
an important factor same thing applies
to an extent at NATO yes many NATO
countries very supportive of Ukraine and
it many surprised by how much support
NATO has given to Ukraine but there are
still some doubters among the NATO ranks
and there's a NATO Summit coming up in
Lithuania in two weeks time again I
think that the fact that this is top of
the agenda again
um perhaps helps those who want further
support for Ukraine and helps the
ukrainians themselves and then there's
how this is viewed around the world in
the global South many have been worrying
about this war and the effect on the
global economy and Global Food and many
have been urging Ukraine just to settle
for peace with Russia even if it meant
giving some territory well those people
might want to think again now
potentially and the last place I think
we need to look is how this is being
seen in China China's put a lot of
effort in its relationship with Russia
it's supposed to have a very strong
alliance with Russia well China may now
be wondering who exactly is signed up to
have this alliance with and whether
Russia and particularly its military is
anything like as powerful as it thought
you have repercussions right around the
world thank you so much that's James
Bays for us at un headquarters
okay well meanwhile in the Ukraine
kiev's forces are pushing south and east
Russia's defense Ministry said its
forces have repelled attacks near
buckmut fighting is also ongoing in the
zaparisia region and west of Donetsk
where Ukraine had retaken several
villages in the past two weeks Jonah
Hull reports from Kiev
it became clear as events unfolded on
Saturday that Ukraine's military command
were going to be doing whatever they
could to try and exploit what was
happening on Russian territory in rostov
online looking for weaknesses in Russian
defenses along the front line perhaps
caused by the redeployment of Wagner
forces and make of it what they could
and by the latter stages of the day we
were hearing about advances that had
been made at various points along the
front notably near bakmut that area in
the East that Wagner mercenaries have
been heavily involved in fighting for
and defending and also word that the
ukrainians had retaken an area called
krasnogorovka that had been occupied by
Russian forces since 2014. now does all
of that add up to a real change in the
Dynamics the overall dynamics of the
battlefield quite possibly not it's more
like a window of opportunity that will
begin to narrow presumably as Wagner
forces are redeployed to the the front
line arguably what does change though is
a perception of Russia's vulnerabilities
the idea that pressure applied on the
battlefield can also add to pressure
inside Russia internally forging cracks
among the elite and potentially even
applying the pressure to the Kremlin and
that is an important morale boost as
Ukraine continues it's counter-offensive
in its early stages we continue to be
told the bulk of prepared forces have
not yet been committed to the fight and
as and when they are it will be with
this added incentive now that success on
the battlefield is not just about
shifting front lines but also
potentially about inflicting pressure
inside Russia uh potentially even
influencing change in the Kremlin